Ani deals with many societal pressures
as a young woman yourself how do you
deal with societal pressures because
like again I you grew up in a different
environment than we did yeah I mean I
think there's a lot of pressure today I
think Friends Place pressure on you
family can place pressure on you as
Society in general places a lot of
pressure there's a lot of expectation
about who you're supposed to be and how
you're supposed to act and how you're
supposed to seem and something we've
talked about a lot is the difference
between you know the person or Persona
that you present you know on the
internet especially as an actress where
you know you want to feel like you're
perfect all the time which is not human
humans are not perfect we're not meant
to be perfect we're meant to make
mistakes and mess up and and do things
wrong and learn and grow like how are
you supposed to get older if you can
never you know learn from mistakes
you're just going to be stunted pretty
much forever yeah so I think there's a
huge pressure when it comes to that I
mean I we were talking about how we you
know I grew up with social media and
Mila didn't and that is hard it's really
hard but you're also incredible at not
um feeding into it we've talked about
this thank you you're very good at
separating what you do and who you are
that's experts very difficult for adults
let alone young and individual I think
that you're gonna you're gonna be fine
but like yeah but I think that that's
the um the minority in this 20 something
year old industry yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]